si vous aimez la viande vous avez
peut-être été content d'apprendre qu'un
projet pilote permettra dix restaurants
québécois de vendre du gibier sauvage
cet automne la fédération des chasseurs
du québec voit le projet d'un autre oeil
voire jean-sébastien cloutier explique
pendant quelques jours à l'automne dans
la cuisine du gastronomique restaurant
toqué du gibier sauvage québécois sera
au menu
le propriétaire normand laprise et
quelques amis chefs demandaient depuis
longtemps à québec de pouvoir en offrir
grâce au projet pilote dix restaurateurs
de la province pourront donc servir du
cerf de virginie du lièvre du castor du
rat musqué et de l'écureuil des
chasseurs et des trappeurs choisi à
l'avance fourniront la viande c'est ce
qui simule un d'avoir une semaine par
année juillet sa vache extraordinaire
que j'ai un sarrau deux arrêts cuisine
et ça fait plaisir d'avoir quelque chose
de pour nous d'autant tic en plus du
toqué trois autres restaurants
montréalais participent au projet le
pied de cochon
joe beef et la maison public est une
question très identitaire l'a donc
valoriser ce keynote note ne patrimoine
en terme naturel en termes de gibier si
je peux m'exprimer ainsi mais oui si
notre culture alimentaire ne peut être
moins de gastronomie chroniqueur du
assez pauvre au québec faut vendre notre
bien commun qui est la forme pierre
latraverse ne décolère pas
québec dit il va à l'encontre du modèle
nord-américain qui se posent à la
commercialisation des produits de la
chasse c'est le principe des déchats
salle commerciaux qui vont aller dans la
forêt profiter de l'ensemble d'un bien
collectif pour en faire un profit
personnel pour certaines gens mais le
projet répond le ministre est très
restreint exemple seule une douzaine de
cerfs de virginie qui proviendront de
l'île d'anticosti seront tués pour cette
première année on exclut une
libéralisation de la chasse qui pourrait
être faite sur le marché dans les
grandes surfaces
c'est pas du tout le conserver mais on
vise une augmentation progressive
on veut élargir les espèces si on est
capable de garder notre encadrement
serré et augmenter le nombre de
restaurants
ce projet pilote est encore loin
ficelez québec va nommer un comité
d'experts qui devra se pencher d'ici
l'automne sur les délicate question de
la traçabilité et de la salubrité du
gibier qui sera vendue le moment les
façons du prélèvement la durée le
transport le les techniques avec
lesquels les bédouins tabet sur la façon
dont les abords ont été traitées tout le
gibier vendu devra être approuvée par le
mapaq normand laprise aimerait que cette
porte qui vient de s'ouvrir men
éventuellement à une nouvelle façon de
gérer les populations animales sont une
surpopulation de 10000 bike dans un
territoire mais il pourrait situer par
deux en deux ans trois ans beaucoup
d'animaux pierre latraverse lui espère
que cette porte se refermera pour éviter
des abus qui qui va empêcher quelqu'un
de vente on conserve de virginie où son
orignal un restaurateur bouscat de
l'homme il ya de l'hommerie les deux
s'entendent au moins sur une chose
vendre la viande des animaux contre ap
comme le castor et le rat musqué sera
plus facilement justifiable leurs
carcasses et souvent abandonnés une fois
la fourrure enlevé et la viande est
gaspillée ici jean sébastien cloutier
radio canada montréal